Nebraska Republican senator Ben Sasse a
member of the Senate Judiciary and Armed
Services Committee joins us from Capitol
Hill senator sass good morning good
morning John thanks for having me thanks
for being here you you said that the
president's comments were bizarre and
flat-out wrong what would you prefer to
have heard from the president we should
tell the American people and tell the
world that we know that Vladimir Putin
is a thug
he's a former caged KGB agent who is a
murderer he's been involved in shooting
down an airliner that killed almost 300
civilians he's invaded Georgia and
Ukraine he's committed cyber attacks on
Estonia he's now trying to destabilize
Germany and France he committed an
attack against the United States and the
American people in 2016 and we say in no
unequivocal terms that we will expose
that kind of attack against America and
we expect to respond to it with cyber
and right now the president isn't
leading that we negotiated from a
position of weakness yesterday and
Vladimir Putin walked away from Helsinki
with a win it's a disaster
senator the white house we just reported
is trying to clean this up maybe get the
president to say something to improve on
his remarks yesterday what do you think
the effectiveness of that will be and do
you draw any larger conclusions about
the president's habits of mind either
with respect to Russia or the globe from
his performance at the press conference
yesterday too often what we seem to see
is a trump first policy rather than an
America first policy an America first
policy that was fully thought out would
be explaining to the American people
that the last 75 years have seen the
greatest period of peace and prosperity
and economic growth around the world in
history NATO isn't just one Alliance
NATO is the most important military
alliance in generations arguably NATO is
the most important military alliance in
two millennia so if the president wanted
to come out and explain that that would
be wonderful news
but right now what happened in Helsinki
just leaves everybody scratching their
heads and when you have that when you
have the choice John to side with
Vladimir Putin or to side with the
Patriots of the American intelligence
community and regardless of what they
might in private be as Republicans or
Democrats there
is no debate inside the US intelligence
community that Russia tried to disrupt
and hack the American election in 2016
but in a way more fundamentally what
they're doing today and planning to do
in the future is continue to sow the
seeds of distrust and undermine American
public confidence when you see that and
you have a choice between siding with
Vladimir Putin are siding with Patriots
in the US intelligence community there's
no choice here the answer is obvious and
yet we didn't see that yesterday
well senator says you put out a list
before the before the meeting saying
he's a thug and a murderer and all the
things that you just outlined but while
President Trump was standing next to him
he said getting along with Russia is a
good thing not a bad thing does he have
a point on that it's certainly better to
get along with your enemies and your
competitors on the global stage than to
get into a hot war with them as long as
you have some sort of clarity about what
you're trying to get along about so
here's what America wants to get along
about we believe that seven and a half
billion people across the globe are
created with dignity that they have the
rights to free speech and assembly and
press and religion and protest not
because a government gives them those
rights but because they're created with
dignity governments just try to secure
rights that people have by Nature and so
if we wanted to articulate what we
believe on the global stage it turns out
that scares the crap out of lad Amir
Putin so what are you going to do about
it now oK we've had the meeting
everyone's talking on both sides what
are you gonna do so first of all we need
to have a shared understanding across
320 million Americans about who we are
and who Putin is so the actual talking
about it that you're doing right now is
really important we shouldn't just let
yesterday be swept under the rug we have
to explain American values and we have
to understand why they're in conflict
with foods what we should also do is we
should be ramping up sanctions on Putin
and his thugs because he's surrounded by
a whole bunch of thugs that hold the
Russian people down America actually
wants to make lots of common cause with
the Russian people
there are many champions of Liberty in
Russia it's just that Vladimir Putin is
against his people we're much more
aligned with the people of Russia than
putin is so more sanctions would be good
number two we need to reaffirm NATO and
we need more military spending in NATO
one of the things the president said
that was right is Germany's flirtation
with cheap energy sources from Russia
is unhelpful to to the NATO alliance and
so we should call that out as well but
in it go ahead yell sorry well it's
beyond a high senator we have to wrap it
and end it here unfortunately but we
should also note that today marks the
four-year anniversary that that airliner
was shot down by the Russians the
president didn't bring that up at all
yesterday in hizmet so we should
Tennessee should be exposing much more
of that when Putin does to maintain a
stranglehold on his power our Intel
agencies know lots of it we should
expose we'll have you back on to talk
more about the senator thank you so much